racializing the royals that's the focus
of tonight's angle Harry and Megan
Princess Diana's youngest son and
American actress Megan Markel blue
brexit off the front pages today by
announcing their engagement after 15
months of dating they traveled to Africa
and found true love
huger refreshing to be able to get to
know someone who isn't necessarily
within your circle doesn't know much
about me I don't know not much about her
so to be able to start almost afresh
right from the beginning and getting to
know each other step by step and then
taking that huge leap of only two dates
and then and then going together in the
middle of nowhere and you know showing
it showing attempt together and what
kind of stuff it was it was it was
fantastic
how sweet and when Buckingham Palace
formally announced the Harry Markel
engagement today Prince Charles and the
Royals couldn't have been more pleased
thank you very much
so basically they're very happy indeed
as a legacy I always feel like I need a
translator I couldn't quite yeah he was
happy and used to expect he's a proud
father but it was the reaction on social
media I was reading some of this on the
way into work today and I was screaming
both laughing and kind of crying but
it's kind of a shocker just moments
after the engagement was announced the
the social media was awash in racial
overtones and this was all because Megan
Marcos father is white and her mother is
black so suddenly tweets and Facebook
posts were harping on her racial
identity now warning you got to forgive
me here there's a lack of basic grammar
and punctuation as in many tweets here
we go some folks in England are about to
lose their minds Megan Marco is biracial
black mom she's older than he is and
she's an American actress hashtag black
royalty another one good time to remind
everyone that Megan Marco is black since
I know y'all gonna try and whitewash the
hmm out of her another
Megan Markos mother Prince Harry's now
future mother-in-law is a black
african-american woman social worker
from LA with sister locks man look if
that's blank don't make you smile big
congrats to the royal fan beam I don't
get fan bail y'all couldn't be more
lucky lucky to get both another one
Megan Marvel is white passing she looks
white she's not even someone that likes
to like that like Jasmine Sanders who
has light eyes and very light skin but
you can tell is black biracial I
straight-up thought that was a tan white
woman another how much black is Megan
Markel I just want to know that that so
I know how much blackness to expect from
this wedding is she black enough for the
cupid shuffle wobble hashtag royal
engagement another to torture you with
y'all Megan Markel is a mixed-race we
got a black princess hashtag Megan
Markel well actually Megan Markel will
not be a princess should be a duchess
and I know we're fascinated by royalty
but must we transfer our racial hang-ups
on to this young happy couple
can't we just celebrate and be happy for
them for their engagement leave it at
that
and as for the racially obsessed and
point of fact Markel will not be the
first black royal in europe that would
be this woman the beautiful princess
Angela of Liechtenstein who married
Prince Maximilian back in 2000 and Megan
Markos race is probably the least
interesting part of this story now why
am I saying that because it turns out
the queen is permitting Harry to Wed not
only a divorcee because Megan was
divorced but possibly more historically
significant a woman who was raised
Catholic so let's forget about the race
of the royal bride or how she identifies
we've had a biracial President of the
United States and we're about to have a
biracial member of the English royal
family but not every moment has to be
about race now let me get get back to my
cyber monday shopping there's a royal
wedding medallion and plates that I can
order and it's apparently 75% I don't
care about the color of the plate either
and that's the angle